bonjour c'est avec un peu d'émotion que
je passe donc le témoin à luc chatel sur
ce conseil national j'en suis très
heureux j'ai une grande confiance en lui
il aura le sens de l' équilibre qu'il
nous faut ici parce que il y à des
discours enflammés mais qui sont
quelquefois un peu clivant et où
quelqu'un il faut des personnalités
qu'ils sachent rassemblé ça ce sera le
travail de luc
merci à lui et merci à notre président
de nous rassembler ce matin moi je pense
que ce qui est important ça doit se
passer dans le parti et c'est pour ça
que je suis là avec les uns et les
autres puisque nous sommes membres du
parti nous discutons dans le parti on
peut tout se dire
et c'est dans le parti qu'on se le dise
je voudrais vous dire aujourd'hui que
c'est une gravité qui me fait prendre la
parole avec vous parce que depuis le
temps que je suis engagé en politique
c'est à dire depuis les années giscard
je n'ai jamais connu une situation aussi
dégradée
je dis pas ça pour un effet tribune
je le pense profondément je n'ai jamais
vu mon territoire de la vienne parents
aussi dégradée 300 dépôt de bilan en
350 en 2015 ça c'est concret on le voit
pas vous regarder la situation de la
france dégradée que vous la comparez
avec les voisins améliorée vous vous
dites bien que là il ya une question de
responsabilité
nous avons depuis 2012 une chômage et
augmenté de 20% en tailleur dans toute
l'union européenne
il a baissé de 10% quand nous avons nous
plus de six cent mille chômeurs les
allemands non moins 400 milles et les
anglais - 800 milles il ya bien quelque
chose qui est profondément dégradée et
regardez notre commerce extérieur
toute ma vie politique j'ai entendu dire
ah si seulement le puits du pétrole
pouvait baisser et bien le prix du
pétrole baisse et on a 45 milliards
de déficit de commerce extérieur et les
allemands tel excédent de plus de 12
milliards que vous payez tous les
paramètres économiques
si vous prenez la dépense publique vous
voyez comme un le monde et le peut-être
le plus grave pour nous la panne de
l'investissement dans les entreprises
l'investissement privé
prenez tous les paramètres ils sont
profondément dégradée les résultats de
nos paies de notre pays sont
catastrophiques et le problème c'est que
les socialistes cachent la vérité aux
français
il cache la vérité en parlant en
permanence de retour de la croissance
d'inversion de courbes qui n'existe pas
on est dans une situation de mensonge
national
la situation est dégradée et face à ces
résultats catastrophiques
c'est le bricolage à tous les étages
quand vous regardez ce remaniement dont
on a beaucoup parlé ray c'est quand même
affligeant
j'en ai jamais vu de comme ça les
banques veulent pas entrer les hulot les
védrines les mauvais comme celui de
l'agriculture veut le rester et
finalement comme au foot on fait jouer
le banc dirait le supporters du paris
saint germain
donc on est dans cette
alors avec un reggae truc énorme moi
j'attends la vénus de la liberté
maintenant et bientôt naturellement je
proposerai que vos pieds soit le
ministre de la fraternité
nous avons toutes les possibilités là
d'avoir des nouveaux et ministère qui
donneront de l'espoir aux 1,11
on nous dit qu'on est en guerre mais
ceux qui sont les plus régaliens que ce
soit à la mise de la défense où le
ministre de l'intérieur le miz intérieur
il est en 14e position dans le
gouvernement et le ministre de
l'économie
il est en 12e position le pauvre on l'a
rétrogradé on a même un ministre de la
biodiversité ça j'attends de voir ça va
être bien ensuite ce bricolage à tous
les étapes je dire sur la réforme
constitutionnelle
alors bien sûr que la déchéance de
nationalité
nous sommes favorables à cette idée mais
fallait-il une réforme constitutionnelle
fallait-il engagé ce processus
aujourd'hui dont on voit bien qu'il a un
rôle de diversion tout ce qui distrait
les français de l'essentiel c'est-à-dire
du chômage c'est bon pour le
gouvernement et donc ont amusé le tapis
avec cette manoeuvre constitutionnel
c'est de la diversion et on voit bien
que tout ceci est à la fois inutile et
au fond dit mobilisant pour le pays
on ne traite pas les sujets de fond on
ne traite pas ce qui est essentiel
aujourd'hui dans les équilibres du pays
c'est à dire la création de valeur la
défense de la production la cohésion
sociale tout ce qui fait notre vivre
ensemble
tout cela laisse de côté et on amuse le
tapis avec des concepts comme ceux de
réformes constitutionnelles ou de
remaniements au fond infligeant des
résultats catastrophiques un bricolage
général et le tout chers amis dans une
situation internationale
on a rarement connu aussi dangereuse
avec une perte d'influencé de la france
préoccupante je ne prends qu'un exemple
mais je le dis sous le regard d'edouard
balladur qui avec le président pompidou
un travail et à l'entrée de la grande
bretagne dans l'union européenne
regardez on est en train de discuter
d'une éventuelle départ des britanniques
et on n'entend pas la france on laisse
négocier ce sujet en dehors de nous
mêmes alors que c'est un sujet qui nous
concerne bien et que les propositions je
le pense qu'ils sont faites aujourd'hui
sont inacceptables remettant en cause un
certain nombre d'acquis communautaires
qui sont pour nous essentiel est que si
on commence à engager une affaire de
marchands de tapis pour savoir si on
peut rester je vous assure que le
processus de plus grave que celui de la
déconstruction de l'europe pourrait bien
être engagée tout ça est révélateur de
la perte d'influencé de la france
comme on le voit dans toutes les crises
et notamment au levant et quand vous
regardez la situation internationale
quand vous voyez monter cette tension
préoccupante
entre la russie et la turquie tension
préoccupante profonde mais aujourd'hui à
vif entre l'iran l'arabie saoudite
si vous ajoutez à cela les conflits plus
anciens de l'inde et du pakistan et si
vous voyez tous les conflits ou
s'exporte les malheurs actuels je pense
au yémen par exemple où s'exporte une
guerre qui vient d'ailleurs et les
problèmes majeurs qui sont posés à un
autre peuple frère qu'est le peuple
tunisien dans sa démocratie naissante
qui aujourd'hui par cette pression
libyenne est fortement fragilisé dans
tout ce contexte là on aimerait entendre
la france
on aimerait voir les lignes politiques
de la france est aujourd'hui on ne
constate que la perte d' influence dans
ce terrorisme dont on a parlé beaucoup
on voit bien qu'il ya eu un combat fort
à mener mais ce combat il n'est pas
seulement à l'extérieur ce combat il est
en nous mêmes
il est dans notre propre société que le
mal est aussi aujourd'hui présent et
donc il nous faut nous combattre avec
force tous ceux qui génèrent le
terrorisme c'est à dire d'abord la
destruction de l'état puis le désordre
puis le développement de toutes les
mafias
mais sur le principal sujet qui a été
plusieurs fois évoquée ce matin je
voudrais vous dire combien je suis
d'accord pour que notre parti s'engage
dans un travail de fond dans une
bataille terrible qu'il nous faudra
mener contre l'islamisme radical
c'est un adversaire ce n'est pas une
folie l'islamisme radical
c'est une idéologie de déconstruction de
destruction de tout ce que nous sommes
de toutes nos valeurs et nous faut
apporter nos propres réponses et je le
dis je le dis vraiment à tous ceux qui
aujourd'hui sont irrités par la présence
d'étrangers en france c'est parce que
nous serons lutter contre l'immigration
illégale
c'est parce que nous sommes lutter
contre le terrorisme que nous serons
aussi dire que la france n'est pas la
haine de l'étranger que la france ne
doit pas se mobiliser contre les autres
que cette force là ce n'est pas la nôtre
nous voulons lutter contre le terrorisme
d'autres ceux qui sont dans notre pays
qu'on profiter de l'accueil et qui le
détruisent
mais ce sont pas tous les étrangers et
ne voulons dire aussi très clairement
dans ce pays qu'est le nôtre avec nos
valeurs que on tue son dieu quand on tue
l'homme
le dieu il est en nous ces laveurs
humaine c'est parce que l'humanisme
aujourd'hui fait de la personne humaine
quelque chose de supérieur de plus gros
c'est ça qui est inatteignable et tu me
tues tu ton dieu assassins de dieu
voilà ce que vous êtes ce qui vous en
prenez à nos valeurs et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut pas hésiter à penser que la
france elle aussi porte ses grandes
idées et ce combat nous devrons le mener
dans ce contexte mais serge amis je
pense que la situation est menaçante que
nous avons devant nous des crises graves
qu'il peut y avoir une crise sociale
très forte
on le voit dans tous nos départements le
jour où les agriculteurs seront rejoints
par les artisans du bâtiment seront
rejoints par tous ceux qui aujourd'hui
sont les entrepreneurs de tpe de pme
tous ceux qui souffrent des difficultés
on sent bien il faut pas avoir l'oreille
musicale aujourd'hui pour sentir que la
france bond et que l'explosion est
possible crise sociale
mais derrière cette crise sociale crise
politique
parce que qui profitent de cette leçon
qui profitent de cette situation c'est
principalement le front national je vous
le dis j'observe la vie politique je la
pratique déjà depuis un certain temps
dans le passé quand l'adversaire échoué
c'était bon pour nous quand on les
voyait se ramasser c'est nous qui après
avions accès au pouvoir
mais aujourd'hui l'échec de la gauche
c'est pas forcément la victoire de la
droite
parce qu'il ya là le front national qui
est là toujours aux avant postes et on
l'a vu de manière terrible aux élections
régionales et qui a été fait par le
gouvernement depuis cette vague du front
national aux dernières régionales qu'a
fait le gouvernement pour limiter
l'impact du français quelle leçon il
tirait moi je dis merci à christian
estrosi
je dis merci à xavier bertrand parce
qu'ils ont donnée par l'action sur le
terrain
parce qu'ils ont fait en donner une
image de gens qui savaient lutte et qui
savait rassembler en gardant les valeurs
mais qui savait que ce qui s'était passé
aux élections régionales
nous ne voulions pas que ça se passe
pour les élections présidentielles c'est
une mission qu'il nous faut assumer et
accusé le gouvernement
le soir des élections ils sont là
effondré sur le score du front national
mais deux mois après quand il fait pour
lutter concrètement sur ce champ de
bataille
quelle bataille des valeurs et de
licques la crédibilité de la politique
alors dans cette france en déclin avec
ses crises menaçante
il y as besoin de ce sursaut républicain
et nous attendons les propositions les
lignes d'avenir qu'il nous faut nous
accrocher moi personnellement je vois
trois priorités
le premier axe c'est de redonner de la
puissance à la politique
ne laissons pas critiquer la politique
c'est parce que la politique aujourd'hui
stérile qu'elle est critiquable mais
c'est la stérilité le problème c'est pas
la politique la politique par définition
c'est la capacité de nous mettre
ensemble pour éviter les problèmes de
violence la politique est inventée pour
surmonter la violence inhérente à une
société
donc tu attends comparé la politique
parce que le jour vous détruisez la
pratique vous détruisez le vivre
ensemble
notre problème aujourd'hui c'est la
stérilité de la politique c'est qu'il ya
des discours c'est qu'il ya des
remaniements ce qu'il ya des annonces de
réformes mais que concrètement les gens
ne voient pas leur situation changer
c'est ce déficit de l'action qu'est le
problème c'est là où il nous faut agir
pour faire en sorte que nous devions
mettre en avant le concret ce que nous
apportons j'appréciais tout à l'heure
quand laurent disait ce qu'il faisait
dans sa région
mettant en avant le travail de nos mères
le travail de président de région
tout ce que nous faisons concrètement
c'est ça la politique si régler les
problèmes des gens c'est d'inventer des
solutions d'avenir
c'est cela que nous faisons concrètement
sur le terrain et c'est là qu'est la
grandeur de l'action politique mais
surtout montrons bien que nous sommes
conscients de cette situation difficile
du pays que le chômage on peut pas
traiter ça
un paramètre égale aux autres égard à la
déchéance de nationalité et galets
remaniement gouvernemental non moi je
pense que l'emploi devrait être une
grande cause nationale
je ne comprends pas pourquoi dans le
pays ne se lève pas une force qui nie
mais ça marche
à l'extérieur ça marche en allemagne ça
marche sans grande bretagne pourquoi ça
ne marche pas chez nous il nous faut sur
ces sujets là essayer de montrer que
nous sommes prêts à ce que la politique
donne des résultats et au fond c'est
possible
de ce point de vue le président hollande
aura fait un mal fou à la politique à la
démocratie et à notre pays quand il a
promis d' inverser la courbe du chômage
et qu'il ne montre même pas la volonté
d'aller re c'est cette courbe du chômage
c'est cette action là qu'il nous faut
engager
de mon point de vue de manière
prioritaire pour redonner de la
puissance à la politique et c'est en
redonnant de la puissance de l'action
que nous pourront remonter la
crédibilité de l'action politique
redonner de la puissante deuxièmement
affirmer notre exigence démocratique
quand on regarde le monde on voit bien
que les régimes autoritaires sont
aujourd'hui très influents dans le monde
je pense évidemment la chine je pense
aussi à la russie je pense à l'iran qui
revient prend sa place autour des tables
datable des nations du monde
ces pays autoritaires ils ont un regard
bien spéciale sur la démocratie
et pourtant la démocratie elle a des
forces considérables
on voit bien ses faiblesses quotidienne
mais on voit aussi au lendemain du 13
novembre au lendemain de notre stratégie
tragédie nationale
on a vu le peuple se rassembler autour
de ses valeurs démocratiques autour de
ces principes démocratiques
je pense que la démocratie quand elle
est menacée elle sait se conforter
autant les dictateurs s'éloigne toujours
de leur peuple parce que comme le disait
montesquieu la dictature se finit
toujours par la folie autant la
démocratie quand elle est menacée elle
sait se rassembler sur l'essentiel
elle sait se rassembler sur ses propres
convictions croyons aux valeurs de la
démocratie à la sagesse populaire
à ce qu'est aujourd'hui notre force dans
le monde ces valeurs que nous devons
toujours défendre et affirmées mais ne
faisons pas en sorte que la démocratie
soit affaiblie par toutes les crises que
nous vivons aujourd'hui
faisons attention à tout ce qui
peut-être dérive autoritaire à tous ceux
qui pourraient un moment ou un autre
affaiblir la démocratie et du maître
dans des processus où finalement à la
fin ce seront nos valeurs qui serait
déclinante alors il nous faut nous même
être exemplaire dans l'exercice de
démocratie interne que nous allons mener
avec ces élections primaires il va
falloir non seulement être des croyants
de la démocratie faudra aussi un peu est
des pratiquants et ça va nous demander
beaucoup de sagesse parce qu'on a tous
de l' enthousiasme
on a tous des préférences on va
s'engager les uns et les autres il va
falloir le faire avec le sens des
responsabilités
en fait la prochaine élection
présidentielle
c'est une élection à 4 tours mais ce que
nous savons c'est qu'au troisième tour
nous devrons tous voter pour celui qui
au deuxième tour aura été désigné par
notre famille politique et donc silva le
résultat c'est bien on va se passionner
pour le premier tour
on va se passionner pour le premier tour
de notre primaire mais il ya quatre
tours les amis alors si on est déchiré
au premier dans quel étant d'arriver au
quatrième donc faisons très attention et
toute façon on un pacte entre nous c'est
que nous votons au troisième tour celui
qui a été désigné par le second essai je
pense à un pratique une pratique
démocratique forte qu'il nous faudra
nous développer soyons exemplaires
faisons en sorte que les primaires ne
soit pas un processus d'exclusion
la primaire c'est parti pour exclure la
primaire c'est seulement une préférence
et on n'exclut pas dans la primaire on
affirme une préférence et nous ferons en
sorte que nous soyons dans notre
pratique démocratique exemplaire
troisième élément est troisième priorité
je pense que nous en parlerons monsieur
le président c'est bien d'avoir les
bonnes idées le bon moment
ce sera aussi très bien de dire comment
aux français on les met en place parce
que on sait très bien que ce qui sera
fait dans la première année sera
déterminée
quel est le calendrier qu'est-ce qui va
levrat du référendum qu'est ce qui
relèvera de la session extraordinaire
qu'est ce qui relèvera de décès par
exemple des ordonnances on a une façon
de faire qui sera aussi importante que
le faire puisque les français doutent de
la crédibilité de la politique
faisons en sorte que à côté de notre
projet politique
la faisabilité de notre projet politique
soient rassurantes pour les français
voilà quelques orientations dans une
situation d'extrême gravité pour notre
pays c'est pour ça qu'il faut avoir
conscience que la politique ce n'est pas
un sport la politique ce n'est pas un
jeu naturellement nous avons quelquefois
ça nous arrive des plaisirs politique
parce que nous ne sommes pas ni les uns
ni les autres
certains plus que d'autres un peu
possédé par la malice
donc il peut nous arriver de nous
écarter mais n'oublions pas à chaque
instant la gravité de la situation
la politique c'est pareil sport la
politique c'est la façon de faire face à
la tragédie c'est la capacité que nous
avons à bâtir un destin pour notre pays
et donc pensons à l'essentiel et mettons
de côté le subalterne dans cette période
grave
la politique peut être grande à
condition que nous soyons capables de la
hisser à la hauteur de la france merci